Harvard withdraws admission from
parkland survivor Kyle cash of the media
help America's enemies against the Trump
administration and we check the latest
polls i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show i hope you had a wonderful
Father's Day or words we here at the ben
shapiro show in true woke fashion like
to call it second legal guardian of
unspecified gender day but if you didn't
good news we're back it's a Monday we're
gonna take you through the whole week
lots of news breaking we'll get to all
of it in just one second first we are
halfway through the area it is never too
late to get started on the things that
you want to accomplish the fact is that
you have a lot of things that you need
to get done one of those things might be
making our business more efficient and
the way to make your business more
efficient is not to spend an enormous
sum of money on your legal costs okay
legal costs are enormous it takes a lot
of time takes a lot of money unless you
use Legal Zoom which is why I have been
using Legal Zoom personally for years it
makes it easy when you have someone to
help you along the way
that's why the Legal Zoom is extending
their friends and family discount to
everybody right now for a limited time
you can get 10% off the things you've
had on your to-do list if you're a small
business owner if you make your
accountant a P by saving on that LLC
d/b/a S corp and more you can also save
time and secure some peace of mind by
wrapping up that last will or living
trust you've been putting off because
once you are done with that you're have
to think about dying anytime soon
legalism is not a law firm but don't
worry if Fleagle questions are holding
you up they have a network of
independent attorneys that can provide
advice to get you over all the legal
hurdles that pop up in your life don't
wait any longer to get started on your
goals this year visit LegalZoom calm
right now save 10% awesome deal with
legal zooms friends and family discount
just be sure to enter code been in the
referral box to check out that offer is
only available for a limited time so
hurry over to Legal Zoom calm right now
use promo code Ben for 10% off that's
legalzoom.com
Legal Zoom where life meets legal ok so
breaking news this morning a kid who I
have found to be strong resilient and
classy Kyle cashew was a parkland
survivor is now being smacked by Harvard
he was admitted to Harvard and now he
has been rejected from Harvard now I
knew about this honestly speaking a
couple of weeks ago Kyle told me about
this a couple of weeks ago when it first
happened he sort of asked my advice on
how to navigate it
I'll tell you the whole story and what
exactly happened too
starting from the beginning so today he
announced on Twitter that Harvard
University had withdrawn his admission
from the school over the revelation of
racist offensive idiotic post written on
a private google document with friends
when he was 16 years old so back when
Kyle was 16 before the Parkland shooting
ever occurred he was on a Google Doc
with a bunch of his supposed friends a
private Google Doc and he dropped the
n-word and a bunch of other disgusting
nasty references now this is something
not to make excuses for bad things but
this is something that 16 year olds
sometimes do because 16 year olds are
stupid everyone knows 16 year olds are
dumb 16 year olds do not have fully
developed prefrontal cortices they are
not geniuses or at least if they are
geniuses they're geniuses for 16 year
olds but if you are a kind of person who
would like everything that you did when
you were 16 said in public or private re
earth Riaan or every time something good
happen to you well then you'll love this
story so Kyle put all this stuff on a
private Google document with supposed
friends then the Parkland shooting
happens and Kyle becomes a very
outspoken advocate for the Second
Amendment a very heavy publicized
heavily publicized figure particularly
on the right on the left there a bunch
of heavily publicized figures from
Parkland ranging from I think her name
was Emily Gonzalez to the to David hog
obviously Cameron caskey who we had on
the Sunday special to talk about
parkland and so they're a bunch of these
survivors and many of them handled him
well some of them don't handle fame as
well but they're all kids right these
are all people who are 17 18 years old
at the most
well Kyle cash was one of these people
and he spends a couple of years
basically going around with various
other members of the parkland class and
trying to develop school safety
initiatives so he meets with a bunch of
senators on both left and right he meets
the President of the United States he
becomes this very prominent figure now
Kyle also has impeccable academic
credentials so Kyle graduated second in
his class his classes several hundred
people he had in a weighted GPA of
something like five point four and he
scored 50 and 50 on his SATs his
academic credentials were firmly in
order see he applies to Harvard and he
gets in and after he gets in some of the
kids who he was on that Google private
doc thread with back when he was 16 when
he said all these terrible things decide
to now drop all of that and
our journalistic institutions decide to
go all-in on this will summer who I
think is one of the worst
gotcha artists in the media I mean he
does this for a living he sort of trolls
Twitter for moments to to attack folks
over at The Daily Beast he prints an
article a couple of weeks ago
he's like May 23rd so about a month ago
now called pro-gun parkland team Kyle
cache of apologizes for inflammatory
racial comments and Kyle had gone ahead
and done that he had called me after he
said this stuff is resurfacing and I
said you should come forward you should
explain to everybody that you apologize
and that you never meant any of this
stuff if you didn't mean any of this
stuff you should explain where you were
coming from and what Kyle said is that
like many 16 year olds he fell in with a
group of people who are trying to shock
each other if you remember being a 16
year old boy
very often 16 year old boys say shocking
and terrible things to each other
specifically for the shock effect so
Kyle came out and he made a statement at
the time and will summer and other
members of the media covered this as
though this was actual news they covered
it as actual news that a 16 year old
said stupid things in a private Google
document and then a lot of his political
adversaries decided to go after him on
that basis there are also misses also
some members of the so-called alright
who decided to go after cash of some
members are sort of the fringy right who
decided to go after cash oof the reason
being that cash who've had to righted
the alt-right for their racism he had
said racism is bad particularly after
parkland he had said that he was not
going to participate in events with
people who he perceived as racist they
said ah hahahaha back when you were 16
you said X these were adults attacking a
kid who is 17 18 years old at the time
and then they all sent these notes to
Harvard's admissions committee
okay so cash ruvé says all this stuff
The Daily Beast reports all of this and
then Harvard gets ahold of it and then
Harvard rescinds his admission so here
is what Kyle explained on Twitter this
morning it's a thread Harvard rescinded
my acceptance three months after being
admitted to Harvard class of 2023
Harvard has decided to rescind my
admission over texts and comments made
nearly two years ago months prior to the
shooting I have some thoughts here's
what happened a few weeks ago I was made
aware of egregious and callous comments
classmates and I made privately years
ago when I was 16 years old months
before the shooting in an attempt to be
as extreme and shocking as possible ayuh
media
the apology apologized and he did in
fact issue an apology by the way side
note here and this is a smear job on
cashew in the sense that they're a bunch
of other sixteen year olds in the chat
have you seen any of their names
appearing in public media have you seen
any of the other sixteen year olds who
said
similarly disgusting and outrageous
things have you seen any of them been
shamed out of their college acceptance
didn't think so so here's the apology
the cashier didn't he the cash of issued
at the time quote I have recently been
made aware of screenshots circulating
that include offensive comments former
classmates and I made a few years ago
long before the shooting I want to
address this with honesty and
transparency we are sixteen year olds
making idiotic comments using callous
and inflammatory language in an effort
to be as extreme and shocking as
possible I'm embarrassed by it but I
want to be clear that the comment I made
are not indicative of Who I am or who
I've become in the year since this past
year has forced me to mature and grow in
an incredibly drastic way my world like
everyone else's in Parkland was turned
upside down On February 14th when your
classmates are teachers and your
neighbors are killed it transforms you
as a human being I see the world through
different eyes and I'm embarrassed by
the petty flippant kid represented in
those screenshots I believe those I've
gotten to know since that and since
since no I'm a better person than that I
can and will do better moving forward
that was his original statement okay and
then he issued the apology speculative
articles were written his peers used the
opportunity to attack him this is what
he writes and my life was once again
reduced to a headline it sent me into
one of the darkest spirals of my life
after the story broke former peers and
political opponents began contacting
Harvard urging them to rescind me sorry
this is disgusting stuff you're going
after a sixteen-year-old who's now a
teen for common to me two years before
in a private google chat and sending it
to harvard administrators in an attempt
to ruin his life this is not an adult as
a person who was 18 years old and was 16
when these comments were made and we're
now going to go to Harvard and try to
have his admission rescinded on the
basis of what that he can never move
beyond that he can never grow as a
person he can never repent we have to
now participate in on Otto Chafee in
which we burn cashiers and people like
him at the stake there's no forgiveness
whatsoever none I mean Harvard could
have done a thousand things here Harvard
could have said listen those comments
were terrible we look forward to working
with you to help you educate yourself
about issues that have troubled you in
the past right I mean there are a
thousand things I could've done Harvard
has people
at Harvard who are ex-convict people who
went to prison for actual crimes against
others not saying bad things not saying
mean things not using racial slurs who
committed actual crimes those are people
at Harvard and you know what that is
perfectly appropriate because if you
committed a crime and you did the time
and you paid your price then why
shouldn't you go to Harvard University
why not what exactly is the problem with
that there are lots of people who I'm
sure believes a lot of terrible crazy
things when they were 16 years old or
said terrible crazy things when they
were 16 years old and who will say and
do crazy and terrible things while they
are at Harvard who are not going to be
tossed out of Harvard hey so Harvard
then sent a letter stating that they
reserve the right to withdraw an offer
of admission and requested a written
explanation within 72 hours they said
mr. Keshav we've become aware of media
reports discussing offensive statements
allegedly authored by you as you know
Harvard reserves the right to withdraw
an offer of admission under various
conditions including if you engage or
have engaged in behavior that brings
into question your honesty maturity or
moral character okay now that right
there that statement is insane if that's
the excuse they are using to kick him
out that he engaged or that he engages
or has engaged in behavior that brings
into question much honesty maturity or
moral character has engaged in so let's
say when he was 11 he said the n-word
okay so now are we gonna make it that
we're like where's the age cutoff here
really especially given the fact that
cashews been in the public eye for two
full-on years after the Parkland
shooting and yet nobody can point to an
incident that he's had post that that
evidence is this kind of racism or
racist behavior says on behalf of the
admissions committee this is William
Fitzsimmons the Dean of Admissions a
gutless hack on behalf of the admissions
committee we right now to ask you to
send us a full accounting of any such
statements you have authored including
not only those discussed in the media
but any others as well please also
provide a written explanation of your
actions for the committee's
consideration please email these
materials to us by no later than 10 a.m.
Tuesday May 28th and they sent this to
my may 24 so he wanted him to to come up
with a full list and they wanted a full
maiya culpa by May 28th so cash you've
complied and he wrote a letter and here
is what the letter said he said let me
first state says let me first state that
I apologize unequip
for my comments which were made two
years ago in private among equally
immature high school students in the
attached document I've attached all the
comments I've been able to record I do
not have access to the electronic record
of that conversation and do not recall
other things that may have been said
I've only seen what has appeared in the
media I take full responsibility for the
idiotic and hurtful things I wrote two
years ago I make absolutely no excuse
for those comments I said them and
regret them and by explaining the
context in my subsequent experiences I'm
not trying to excuse them instead I'm
seeking to demonstrate the hurtful
things I said do not represent the man I
am today
I understand Harvard's concern over
these offensive statements from my past
and I further understand that Harvard
has been contacted about them by people
expressing concern about them I am very
sorry to have put the college in this
position I'm determined to take whatever
steps are necessary to rectify this past
wrong and to reassure Harvard of my
commitment to values of tolerance
diversity and inclusion which I hope to
advance as a member of the class of 2024
this is the context in which I made
these comments while this does not
excuse my comments I made poor choices
with a group in which those wards words
bore little weight and were used only in
a means for their shock value I borne no
racial animus the context was a group of
adolescents trying to use the worst
words and say the most insane things
imaginable until these writings were
disclosed I had long forgotten about
them well I will forever bear incredible
shame for typing them I especially feel
remorse now that they've been made
public knowing they've caused terrible
pain to people I care about
I gave no consideration to the meaning
and weight of the words I wrote in an
effort to impress then friends and
classmates and looking back I know
clearly now
I wrote terrible things I can never
unright my intent was never to hurt
anyone to do so would have magnified the
harm immensely I also feel I am no
longer the same person especially in the
aftermath of the Parkland shooting and
all that has transpired since in a
second I'll read you the end of Kyle's
response to Harvard's request for maiya
culpa first let's talk about that suit
you're wearing so I know you go to work
and you're wearing a suit you just got
it off the rack you know this probably
fits me great it doesn't okay it's
really ugly instead what you need is a
suit that is made just for you this is
where endo Chino comes in endo Chino is
the world's most exciting
made-to-measure menswear company they
make suits in shirts to your exact
measurements for an unparalleled fit and
comfort if you're in the middle of
planning a wedding they have tons of
options for those looking to outfit
their wedding party so here's how it
works you can visit a stylist at one of
their showrooms Indo Chino has over 40
showrooms in North America they will
take your measurements personally or you
can measure at home and shop online at
Indo Chino com choose your fabric your
design customizations simply submit your
measurement
with your choices online relax while
your soup gets professionally tailored
and mailed to you in a couple of weeks
this week my listeners can get any
premium Indo Chino suit for just 369
bucks at Indo Chino calm when you enter
promo code Shapiro at checkout that is
50% off the regular price from
made-to-measure premium suit plus
shipping is free I have an Indo Chino
suit it is perhaps my favorite suit it
is fantastic it fits perfectly because
it was tailored just for me that's Indo
Chino comp remote coach Shapiro for any
premium suit just 369 bucks and free
shipping is an incredible deal for a
premium made-to-measure suit once you go
custom you're not gonna want to go back
you're gonna look fantastic go check
them out at Indo Chino calm and use
promo code Shapiro for any premium suit
just 369 bucks and free shipping
okay so Kyle continues in this letter
back to Harvard he says my intent was
never to hurt anyone to do so would have
magnified the harm immensely I also feel
I am no longer the same person
especially in the aftermath of the
parkland shooting and all that has
transpired since I had to mature not
only to address that horrible situation
but to fulfill my new role as a school
safety activist I've tried hard to be a
better man in honor of the friends I
lost and I believe I have grown and
matured significantly through this
experience I'm proud of some of the
things I've accomplished in the wake of
that tragedy and I do not recognize the
person who wrote those things when I was
reminded of the writings I was mortified
and embarrassed my parents raised me to
be better than what is represented in
these screenshots from about two years
ago in an effort to be as honest and
transparent as possible I immediately
apologized publicly when reminded of
these messages while knowing the media
uproar that would ensue it didn't sue
and I've continued to accept
responsibility and the resulting
legitimate criticism as you know I
intend to take a gap year before
beginning my studies to continue my work
promoting school safety I will continue
to mature and will enter Harvard with
three years and many life experiences
between the foolish child who said those
things in the man I am today as an
aspiring member of the Harvard community
I aspire to the values that the
community strives to uphold therefore I
have already written to the Harvard
College of diversity education and
support both to express my deepest
apologies and remorse and to reach out
to begin a dialogue that I hope will be
the foundation of future growth
well I'm no longer the same person who
wrote those comments there's always more
to learn especially about the legacy of
racism in our society thank you again
for this opportunity to address these
issues
I hope this fully addresses your
concerns but if not I would be happy to
provide any further information or
discussion you require okay so that's
the letter that cash you've wrote back
to them and then he also sent a letter
to the Office of Diversity I'll read
at to you in a second so cashew doesn't
just respond to Harvard admissions
asking for some sort of justification
with what I think is a very classy
letter taking full blame for what he did
but also recognizing that he has grown
as a human being since he was 16 years
old and saw his friends shot hey and
then he issued another letter this one
to the Office of Diversity quote to
Harvard College Office of diversity and
support around two years ago when I was
16 years old before the mass shooting
that occurred at my high school Marjory
Stoneman Douglas I was part of a group
in which we used abhorrent racial slurs
we did so out of a misplaced sense of
humor we tweeted that we treated the
words themselves as though they bored a
little weight and used them only for
their shock value looking back two years
later I cannot recognize that person I
make absolutely no excuse for those
comments I said them and regret them
deeply I bore no racial animus
whatsoever the context was a group of
adolescents trying to use the worst
words and say the most insane things
imaginable my intent was never to hurt
anyone and then he continues along the
same lines as his original letter to the
to the admissions committee on June 3rd
then right back to and they say dear mr.
Kashyap thank you for your response to
our letter of May 24th the admissions
committee has discussed at length your
accounts of the communications about
which we asked and we appreciated your
candor and your expressions of regret
for sending them as you know the
committee takes seriously the qualities
of maturity and moral character after
careful consideration the committee
voted to rescind your admission to
Harvard College we are sorry about the
circumstances that have led us to
withdraw your admission and we wish you
success in your future academic
endeavors and beyond so in other words
you're an irredeemable racist and now we
are going to ensure that you don't get
into Harvard College and that your smear
to such for the rest of your life
because your political opponents unearth
stuff from when you were 16 years old
that you said when you were young and
stupid congratulations your academic
life has basically been ruined by the
way I've spoken with Kyle what Kyle told
me is that he turned down a full ride
from NYU's he turn down hundreds of
thousands of dollars in forgone student
debt said he could attend Harvard
College they waited until after that to
reject his admission by the way he got a
letter the same day from the office of
diversity and inclusion saying quote
hello Kyle I hope this message finds you
well thank you for your email we
appreciate your thoughtful reflections
and look forward to connecting with you
upon your matriculation in the fall of
2020 in the interim I encourage you to
search online for different ways to
connect to local
organizations and resources within your
community have a wonderful day best
grace Harvard College Dean of Students
office Office of Diversity education and
support so excellent job Harvard your
own diversity office is like okay they
did the mature thing we look forward to
seeing you here we hope that you've
learned and grown and we look forward to
teaching you
Harvard admissions committee rejected
him expelled him effectively speaking
hey after receiving Harvard's letter
cashew then responded by asking for an
opportunity to make his case face to
face and work toward any possible path
toward reconciliation and they said no
they said thank you for a correspondence
we understand this outcome is
disappointing please be aware the
admissions committee carefully and
thoroughly considered your application
reaching its determination decisions of
the admissions committee are final we
wish you the best okay so I have a
couple of notes about Harvard University
one Harvard University is currently
embroiled in a scandal where they have
been rejecting Asian applicants on the
basis of their race okay that is a
decision of the admissions committee so
the admissions committee is racist
enough that they are rejecting Asian
applicants on the basis of their race
alone and they're in the middle of a
lawsuit about this right now but if a
kid said something when he was 16 years
old and is demonstrated full-scale that
not only is he remorseful but that's not
who he is as a person then Harvard Danes
to expel him based on unearthed private
correspondence from when he was 16 years
old that's number one number two is this
a new standard like this is the new
standard now that anybody who anybody
who has their crap from when they were
16 unearthed and then passed into public
view no matter what they have done since
no matter what they've gone through or
what they've become as a person and that
person's academic life gets ruined and
that person is then smeared across
academia that a person can earn
admission to Harvard not on the basis of
activism as some of Kyle's classmates
did let's be real about this there are
certain of Kyle's classmates who did not
score appropriately to get into places
like Harvard or Columbia and they are
attending places like Harvard and
Columbia solely on the basis of their
activism hal is not one of those he
finished number two in his class with a
5.4 weighted GPA in a 1550 on his SATs
he gets into Harvard regardless of
anything happens at Parkland and let's
be real about this too if he had not
been involved in being a public activist
after Parkland none of this ever comes
out because none of his
opponents are looking to dig up dirt on
him so he would have gotten into Harvard
regardless and none of this ever would
have come out and he never would have
had to apologize and he never would have
been rejected from admission in the
first place he would've gotten into an
Ivy League anyway he was going to a
massive public school graduate number
two out of something like 800 kids in
his class he was going to an Ivy and now
he's been rejected for the crime of
having put his face in public that's
really what this is about if he were not
in public
none of this ever comes out and if you
say well this is really but who makes
these kinds of comments when they are 16
years old
hey I urge you to go back and look at
the crap you said and did when you were
16 years old and think about whether you
would want the private stand not even
the public stuff which is bad enough I'm
sure the private stuff that you said
unearthed and then cast before the world
view the world's view and you being
given no grace at all that's the new
standard by the way this is not about
Kyle being conservative for me I've
worked at many of the Parkland survivors
several of them
Cameron Caskey was on my show as I say
Cameron disagrees with me on gun rights
I would absolutely defend Cameron the
same way I have defended people on the
left in the exact same way
Sara John who's a columnist for the New
York Times with whom I heartily disagree
on politics said vile things on Twitter
people unearthed it when she was hired
by the New York Times I said she
shouldn't even lose her job and she was
an adult when she said those things and
she said them publicly on Twitter not
privately when she was 16 years old when
James Gunn the director of the guardians
of the galaxy franchise was targeted by
online activists with old tweets where
people were looking through his old
tweets and they found bad old jokes that
he had told publicly about molesting
children I said he should not be fired
this was bad old stuff he had apologized
for it in the past also it was comedy
right and I defended him too this is not
about Kyle being conservative I will
tell you what is about Kyle being
conservative the left targeting Kyle is
about him being conservative because it
I promise you if Kyle were on the Left
none of this ever sees the light of day
nobody on the Left unearths it nobody
covers it in the media if this had
happened to David hog the entire media
infrastructure activates in order to
defend him when Laura Ingram committed
the grave sin of suggesting that David
hog was spoiled boycotts were started
against her program based on media
coverage of Ingram with
- of his political opponents from high
school his high school quote unquote
friends target him and The Daily Beast
runs full pieces one just The Daily
Beast by the way Huffington Post around
a piece I believe a bunch of outlets did
and then everybody descends on Harvard
to try and get these kids and mission
revoked
that's disgusting enough what Harvard
did is even worse Harvard is a place
supposedly of education my alma mater
Harvard Law School I'm ashamed of that
school today I'm ashamed of my alma
mater
I'm ashamed and I'm not the only one I
know a bunch of folks who went to
Harvard to Harvard Law School who are
deeply ashamed of that admittance titute
inand they damn well should be I'll
explain more in just a second first my
kitchen is under construction right now
that means that I don't really have the
ability to cook which means I am deeply
reliant on people providing food to me
from restaurants and that means I need
door - if you've had a long day at work
a tough day at school if you're still
stuck at the office treat yourself to
the meal you deserve on demand from your
favorite restaurant restaurants come to
you with door - door - connects you to
your favorite restaurants in the city
ordering is super easy just use the door
- app choose what you want to eat - sure
we'll bring it to you anywhere you are
not only is that burger place you love
on tour - already over three hundred ten
thousand other amazing restaurants are -
door - connects you with door to door
delivery in over 3300 cities all 50
states in Canada order from your local
goat cheese or choose from your favorite
chains like Chipotle or Wendy's or
chick-fil-a and the Cheesecake Factory
don't worry about dinner
let's dinner come to you with door -
right now our listeners can get five
bucks off their first order of 15 bucks
or more when you download the door - app
and enter promo code Ben that's five
bucks off your first order when you
download the door - app from the app
store and enter promo code Ben again
that is promo code Ben for five bucks
off your first order from door - the
Oliver deal and let me tell you
something door - makes life so easy I
mean I'm like Thor - basically is what
is keeping my family fed at this point
youth promo code Ben for five bucks off
your first order from door - okay so
back to Harvard's standards here so
again the new Harvard standard is if
your political opponents dig up
something that you said privately when
you were 16 years old and then dump it
in front of the Harvard's admissions
committee and you happen to be
conservative and it happens to be
something terrible and doesn't matter
what you've done since then Harvard will
get rid of you they the ex-cons they're
right ex-convicts which is perfectly
appropriate by the way I am sure and if
we start going through the so
Media posts of everybody who's been at
Harvard for the past several years I
promise you there's some real ugly crap
there that's just social media not what
they've been saying privately again this
wasn't even public this is private this
is an insane standard no one can uphold
but it shows the absolute gutless Ness
of the Harvard administration let us all
recall that Elizabeth Warren now a
leading contender for the Democratic
nomination for president spent years
claiming she was a Native American and
being listed as such in the faculty
handbook at Harvard Law School and she
has felt no blowback whatsoever
from the Harvard from the Harvard
administration none none if you ask them
about it today they will still defend
her and pretend that nothing bad to
happen ever she lied to them about her
own status for years lied to them no
problem hey Harvard again is engaged in
an admission scandal right now in which
they have been using racism in order to
reject Asian candidates maybe they found
out Kyle was Asian that was the problem
hey Harvard has a long history of racism
and anti-semitism Harvard has a long
history of discrimination but you know
what as Kyle points out he says I
believe institutions and people can grow
I've said that repeatedly throughout its
history Harvard's faculty has included
slave owners segregationist bigots and
anti-semites if Harvard is suggesting
that growth is impossible and that our
past defines our future then Harvard is
an inherently racist institution but I
don't believe that in the end this isn't
about me it's about whether we live in a
society in which forgiveness is possible
or mistakes brand-new is irredeemable as
Harvard has decided for me so what now
says Kyle I'm figuring it out I had
given up huge scholarships in order to
go to Harvard and the deadline for
accepting other college offers has ended
I'm exploring all options at the moment
I mean this is what a disaster for
Harvard and unfortunately this is what
Harvard has become Harvard is now a
member of the wokes cold brigade they
are run by SJW idiots they have been by
the way even when I was there and they
were trying to get rid of larry summers
as dean because larry summers had the
temerity to suggest that there are
natural differences between men and
women that was enough to get him
rejected and of course over the past few
weeks we've seen the case of ronald
Sullivan a a black leftist member of
Harvard Law School's faculty who has
acted as a defense lawyer in a bevy of
cases acted as a defense lawyer for
Harvey Weinstein and
getting his deanship of a residential
hall canceled on him Harvard is no
longer an educational institution it is
an institution of a tyrannical overlord
ship based on politics it's ridiculous
because what you would assume is that
this is a place where you would come to
be educated again let's say that you
just had a student you know random
student and the student had racist views
at Harvard wouldn't it be Harvard's job
as a school to try and train that
student out of the racist views wouldn't
be Harvard's job as a school to try and
work with especially if the student
expressed interest to try and work with
the student to educate the student
beyond the stupidity wouldn't that be
the idea I mean we're better to go then
to an educational institution that is
capable of educating people out of bad
ideas when I was reading a book over the
weekend by a guy who will have on our
program his name escapes me at the
moment
it's Jamil jivani I believe Jamil jivani
he has a great new book called why young
men about why young men become violent
become terrorists why they become
criminals very often and Jamil jivani
grew up in Toronto he was the the son of
effectively a single mother mixed-race
background his father was black his
mother was white and he talked about how
as he grew up he inculcated all of these
ridiculous and insane views I mean he
actually fell in with the Nation of
Islam at one point he fell in with the
five percenters who are a bunch of
racist folks and then he ends it up
because he was a gifted guy he ended up
scoring well on his else that's and
going to Yale Law School and in the
process of that education he learned
that a lot of these ideas were wrong
because this is one of the things that
happens when you go to an educational
institution it is designed to educate
you to give you new information and
perspectives you hadn't thought about
now imagine if Yale Law School had said
Jamil jivani
you know what no you know we see that
you were once a member of the Nation of
Islam you can't get in
we're done here sorry you said that
you'll remember the Nation of Islam and
that means that your irredeemable and
you can never change in any way even
though you are 18 years old 20 years old
well that's what Harvard has done here
mainly because they were afraid of the
blowback from the social justice
warriors they were afraid I am sure the
Black Student Association was going to
descend on the doors of the Dean of
office and protests and make them look
bad and then it would be Harvard admits
racist Harvard admits racist that was
gonna be how the media covered it so
Harvard was scared of the same media
that is despicable enough to say that
he's 16 year old in private conversation
saying a bad thing for which he
apologizes and then spends years trying
to live down that media was interested
in bullying Harvard that's why those
articles came out in the first place and
Harvard cabe because they have no spine
that's the story of our social justice
day and age a media that is not a media
that is not a journalistic institution
they're pseudo journalists who are
actually activists who are determined to
use institutional power to club everyone
else into submission and a bunch of
administrators at these various
institutions who are willing to cave in
because they don't want the pressure
Harvard made a very simple decision here
this is not about principle because the
principle is unlivable this is a very
simple decision by Harvard University
the decision is we would rather cave in
to the woke schooled media and their
allies these pseudo journalists
activists and their activist friends
we'd rather cave into them than stand up
for principle of academic freedom and
repentance this is dangerous stuff for
the country so here's what I'm
suggesting if you are a Harvard alum
today you should seriously consider
withdrawing your donations to Harvard
I've never been a donor to Harvard Law I
might have considered at one point they
are not getting any donation from me
that's for damn sure
and if you are an alum from Harvard you
should think seriously about whether
your money ought to go to an institution
that decides that 16 year olds are
irredeemable based on private posts that
are unearthed by political opponents two
years after the fact in order to hurt
them and the admissions committee goes
along with that I would also suggest
that media members if you want to do
some digging and if you're not just
activists if you're just concerned about
people in positions of power who are
maybe holding bad views maybe your job
should be not to go after sixteen year
olds maybe your job should be to look at
Harvard's admissions committee and find
out what exactly they have been saying
on their social media for years weird I
noticed that everyone in the Harvard
admissions committee that I could find I
noticed that all of them had their
social media accounts locked I wonder
why that is
I wonder why they've locked those I mean
don't they want to be transparent and
open about their viewpoints hmmm
very weird very weird a little bit more
on this in a second and then we'll get
to the media engaging in another kind of
insanity first let's talk about the fact
that you might need a new job so you're
working a job and it's alright but why
wouldn't you want to upgrade well
finding any jobs a lot of work I mean
that's the chief barrier but what if you
had your own personal recruiter to help
you find a better job well now zip
recruiters technology can do that for
you just download the zip recruiter job
search app let it know what kind of jobs
you're interested in and it's technology
starts doing the work the zip recruiter
app finds jobs you'll like and put your
profile in front of employers who may be
looking for someone like you if an
employer likes your profile zip
recruiter lets you know so if you're
interested in the job you can apply no
wonder zip recruiter is the number one
rated job search app my listeners should
download the free zip recruiter job
search app today and let the power of
technology work for you don't wait the
sooner your download the free zip
recruiter job search app the sooner it
can help you find a better job go check
them out right now go download that free
zip recruiter job search app and get
yourself a better job I mean unless
you're working here if you're working
here then please don't download the free
zip recruiter job search app this is the
best job you can have but if you're
working somewhere else and you like more
work it's a lee weyer for example then
one of the ways that you would do so is
to download that free zip recruiter job
search app and that's how you find the
job that works best for you it works
great for employers and employees and
prepares fantastic go check them out now
EDD zip recruiter comm and download that
free zip recruit job search app on your
phone as well ok so we're gonna get to a
little bit more on this Harvard insanity
because I really do think it's
indicative of something deeper in
American public life that cannot be
cannot be lived down in something I've
talked about a lot and that is the
choice that is now being forced on
people basically do not enter public
life unless you are shameless or unless
you're willing to let people destroy you
now that's basically the choice that is
now being placed before the American
public and it's disgusting we'll get to
that in just one second first head on
over to daily wear comm for $9.99 a
month you can get the rest of this show
live you can also get two additional
hours of the show every afternoon I
believe Kyle's gonna be a guest on the
show the after this afternoon along with
Dennis Miller a bunch of folks who come
on every day it's really fantastic if
you're missing out you are missing out
so go check it out at daily where I come
also the sort of woke scolding that I'm
talking about with Kyle applies to the
entire right okay the entire left is
intent on depriving you of your ability
to listen to shows like this one they're
attempting to go after our advertisers
it's something they do every single day
it's why we appreciate our advertisers
but it's also
we really appreciate you the subscribers
so please go subscribe for $99 a year
you get this the leftist here is hot or
cold tumblr go check it out right now
it is indeed fantastic and you get all
these goodies but more importantly you
know that you're helping us bring the
show to you every day so that we can't
be run off the air by leftists who are
intent on shutting down political debate
by targeting folks go check us out over
a daily we're done with all sorts of
goodies our last Sunday special was
great with Larry Wilmore
he's on the Left which is always I think
a lot of fun to talk with people who
disagree you can go check that out you
would have gotten that a day earlier if
you were a subscriber as well so all
sorts of goodies for you when you
subscribe we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
so one of the things that I think is
worth pointing out here is the broader
standard that has now been established
so we've seen it already with folks like
Ralph Northam that if you do something
earlier in your life at least northern
was like 25 when he was in med school
and took a picture in blackface or a KKK
hood you got to pick one yeah at least
he was 25 so saying that he was doing
something racist when he was 25 that's a
lot worse than doing something racist
when you are 16 years old but even with
that said I said even in the middle of
the Ralph Northam saga that if you spend
the next thirty years of your life not
being a racist this should weigh into
the consideration as to whether you are
actually a racist but what northern
ended up doing is basically saying he
wasn't in the photo and now he's able to
live this down so here is what has
happened if Kyle had never Kyle kashyap
had never entered the public square he
would've been in Harvard he did under
the public square and then he got into
Harvard and then his political opponents
targeted him so what does this say about
getting into politics what does this say
about sounding off on matters of public
discourse and public opinion it means
that if you have the right opinions you
will be guarded no matter what you do if
you are on the Left you will be guarded
by the media no matter what you do
because amazing but people stopped
talking about Ralph Northam and not
weird people just stop stop talking
about him it's really crazy now if
you're a Republican they would never
stop talking about him but Ralph Northam
they all just kind of shook their head
and went on with their life after all he
holds the correct political positions
that's the way this works if you're
Sera's young and you have old racist
tweets everybody just goes oh well you
know that's Sarah that's whatever
whatever
if you're James Gunn everybody
eventually moves on even for James Gunn
if you're on the right you are forever
tarred and feathered and this double
standard only applies to you once taught
one side obviously which is why it is a
double standard but even more
importantly than that if you enter the
public public square you know that you
will be exposed to scrutiny on
everything that you have ever done and
there will be no forgiveness if you have
the wrong political perspective which
means that you're going to end up with
people who are either shameless you know
people who don't really care like you
expose them they just go ahead and they
said fine expose me and I'm just gonna
double down on that you wanted with joy
read over at MSNBC claiming she was
hacked or people so shameless or people
who attempt to hide everything right
those are the only
two alternatives people who are either
absolute blank slates who have said
nothing in the past so you have no
actual read on them or are people you
have a read on and the read is they're
shameless those are the only two types
of people who will rationally enter
public life ever again because everyone
who is honorable I am sure would
apologize for bad things in their life
but the apology does not matter that's
the point
Kyle apologized Kyle has attempted to be
a better person
Kyle moved on and it wasn't enough which
means that the normal good human being
who makes mistakes at court across the
course of their life and speaks publicly
and openly and tries to add their
opinions in the public discourse that
person gets ruined the only people who
are welcome are people who are absolute
anodyne enigmas you have no idea who
they are
right there's blank slates like Barack
Obama who don't really have a public
record or you ends up with people who
are utterly shameless or both that's
what you end up with in public life this
wrecks our public discourse our
educational institutions obviously have
already been wrecked this is probably
it's got to be one of the worst moves
I've ever seen in academia I mean to
reject a student on the basis of old
private posts that again you can show no
evidence that Kyle has ever acted in a
racist way other than these posts and
the posts are bad he apologized for them
he was 16 they were private and they
were unearthed by political opponents in
the media amazing amazing stuff okay
meanwhile our media you know our
honorable dutiful beautiful folks in the
press the guardians of our freedoms you
know the people who are really on the
front lines of ensuring me you get the
information you need like what a 16 year
old said in a private Google Doc back
when he was a junior or sophomore in
high school we need those people on the
front lines we especially need them on
the front lines when they are basically
doing the work of the Iranian government
so over the past week we've seen the
Iranian government really escalate its
attacks in the Middle East they attacked
allegedly and and by all available
evidence they attacked a couple of
tankers in the Gulf of Oman this is the
second time they've done this in the
past four months and this has really
raised a lot of tensions in the Middle
East and by the way there's a bipartisan
consensus among people who have seen the
intelligence that this is what happened
now it's amazing when there was a
bipartisan consensus in the intelligence
community that
Russia impacted the election or tried to
impact the election then everybody
ripped on Trump right because Trump
denied it and their right to rip on
Trump because when the Intel community
says something and there's a pretty good
and there and there's a pretty good
consensus on it the chances are pretty
good that it's right even when it came
to WMD in Iraq the reason that the
intelligence community worldwide got it
wrong was not because of the Bush
administration seeking to go to war it
was because the international
intelligence community universally was
lied to by Saddam Hussein there's a
reason that the Brits and the French and
the Germans everybody's intelligence
services were coming up with the same
answer on that one so for all the talk
about how this was all manipulated and
our intelligence community this and that
it's the Intel committee you got to pick
one either you trust them or you don't
weird how everybody trusts the
intelligence community on Russian
interference in the election but
suddenly it comes to Iran and they don't
anymore by the way there is bipartisan
understanding that Iran is behind these
things so Mike Pompeo the Secretary of
State said over the weekend that there
is no doubt that Iran is behind these
attacks how certain are you that Iran
was responsible for these attacks and do
you have more evidence that you can
share with us Oh Chris it's unmistakable
what happened here these were attacks by
the Islamic Republic of Iran on
commercial shipping on the freedom of
navigation with the clear intent to deny
transit through the Strait this was on
the Gulf of Oman side of the Strait of
Hormuz there's no doubt the intelligence
committee has lots of data lots of
evidence the the world will come to see
much of it but the American people
should rest assured we have high
confidence with respect to who conducted
these attacks as well as a half a dozen
other attacks throughout the world over
the past 40 days okay so the media seek
to paint this is propaganda and the
media seek to say no this is propaganda
and and this is exactly what Russia is
pushing right this is the line Russia's
pushing so Moscow the Kremlin on Sunday
warned against the baseless accusations
of her last week's attack in the Gulf of
Oman on two oil tankers blamed by
Washington and Riyadh on Iran such
incidents can undermine the foundations
of the world economy that's why it's
hardly possible to accept baseless
accusations in this situation said
Kremlin spokesman Dmitry Peskov Peskov
said we always heard just sober or
appraisal of the situation and to wait
for more or less convincing evidence to
appear worth noting the Russian
basically denied for years that Bashar
Assad had ever used chemical weapons
against his own people
the Russians needless to say are not
folks to trust when it comes to this
because they've been on Iran side they
were important in building the the
nuclear reactor in Iran they've been
instrumental in Iran's gaining regional
power they've stood with Iran in all of
that and then Iran of course is pushing
this too so Iran's Parliament speaker
hints it on Sunday that Washington was
behind the suspicious tanker attacks ah
it was a false flag attack so basically
everybody's going Alex Jones now she got
Moscow and Iran well say no no no no
wasn't the obvious Iranian attack I mean
sure there's tape of us you know like
removing an unexploded mine from a ship
on our rinky-dink Navy but you know it
was probably the Americans probably
Saudis or something it was somebody else
so this is when when propaganda is being
repeated by Moscow and Iran the media
might want to you know take a little
break and think hmm maybe maybe this
doesn't have a lot of credibility so
here's the headline from The Washington
Post standoff with Iran exposes Trump's
credibility issue as some allies seek
more proof of tanker attack Japan and
Germany have requested stronger evidence
than a grainy video released by the
Pentagon now you might be saying to
yourself as Paul Krugman at the New York
Times saying ought to wag the dog attack
first of all if there's a wag the dog
sort of scenario then what exactly is
from wagging the dog away from you think
he wants to go to war in the Middle East
what do you think I would do for his
approval ratings it gonna be good I
think raising the price of oil in the
midst of a shaky economy is a good idea
probably not but here's the other thing
Democrats are repeating what Trump said
so when you have Mike Pompeo and Adam
Schiff saying the same thing pretty good
indicator that perhaps that thing is
true so here's the Adam Schiff a man
that compares no love for president
Trump apparently he is now involved in
the evil wag the dog scenario so Adam
chef who Trump has termed pencil-neck
and who hates Trump with a passion
bordering on the insane Adam Schiff was
saying over the weekend there was no
question that Iran was behind the
attacks so apparently it's a bipartisan
wag the dog scheme there's no question
that Iran is behind the tax I think the
evidence is very strong and compelling
in fact I think this was a class-a
screw-up by Iran
to insert a mine on the
it didn't detonate they had to go back
and retrieve it I could imagine there
are some Iranian heads rolling for that
botched operation but nonetheless the
problem is that we are struggling even
in the midst of this solid evidence to
persuade our allies to join us in any
kind of a response and it shows just how
isolated the United States has become
okay well you know what would help Adam
Schiff is if you went out there and
forcibly made the case that the Trump
administration is correct on what is
going on with regard to Iran but here's
the bottom line there's a bipartisan
consensus in Washington DC from Adam
Schiff to Mike Pompeo that Iran is
behind these attacks naturally that
means the de media are siding with Japan
Germany the Iranians and the Russians
well done media you know you guys are
just doing yeoman's work not only that
not only are they doing amazing work so
there's an article within New York Times
this is just insane so the New York
Times prints an article u.s. escalates
online attacks on Russia's power grid
the United States is stepping up digital
incursions into Russia's electric power
grid in a warning to President Vladimir
Putin and a demonstration of how the
Trump administration is using new
authorities to deploy cyber tools more
aggressively current and former
government officials said so nothing
says you know standing up to the
Russians quite like giving over a bunch
of confidential information to the
Russians via the New York Times
well done New York Times so the same New
York Times who accuses Trump of being a
Russians cat paw in the pay of Vladimir
Putin that same New York Times is
printing articles on their front page
about how the United States is attacking
the electric grid based on confidential
and classified information the New York
Times says in interviews over the past
three months
the officials described the previously
unreported deployment of American
computer code inside Russia's grid and
other targets as a classified companion
to more publicly discussed action
directed at Moscow's disinformation and
hacking units around the 2018 midterm
elections buried in this article is this
hilarious aside there's an aside in
which the New York Times reports that a
bunch of people in the US government
were hesitant to tell President Trump
about this because they were worried
what President Trump might do quote
Pentagon and intelligence officials
described broad hesitation to go into
detailed mr. Trump about operations
against Russia for concern over his
reaction
and the possibility that he might count
remand it or discuss it with foreign
officials as he did in 2017 when he
mentioned a sensitive operation in Syria
to the Russian Foreign Minister so let
me get this straight let me get this
straight
pentagon and intelligence officials were
worried that Trump might spill this
information to the Russians or stop it
so they went and spilled it to the New
York Times who put it on their front
page
now that's patriotism right there I mean
look that is some patriotic deep state
stuff right there you're worried that
the president might do something you
don't want him to do so instead what you
do is you dump it in full public use of
the Russians know exactly what we're
doing and the New York Times runs with
it because they're patriotically
standing up for America's interests our
press democracy dies in darkness
these folks I definitely trust them I
think they are not activists I think
they are definitely definitely
journalists you wonder why the the
credibility the precedent all-time low I
would suggest that it might have
something to do with the fact that
they're taking the word of Moscow and
Iran over that of America's intelligence
community except when it benefits them
to to stand with the intelligence
community against the Trump
administration simultaneously attacking
seventeen-year-old eighteen-year-old
college admittees and ensuring that the
Russians know about secret American
interference with their electric grid
great job pres you guys are really
outdoing yourselves okay time for some
things I like and then some things that
I hate so things that I like today so
George Will has come under a lot of fire
from a lot of folks on the right side of
the aisle because he is militantly
anti-trump the reason that he's
militantly anti-trump is he has said is
because he believes that Trump does not
have the character to be President now
as I have said you know I said at the
time that Trump's character is not my
thing I said this in 2016 I'm still very
critical of president Trump's character
as anyone who listens to the show on a
regular basis notes so I don't disagree
with george will's characterization of
President Trump in terms of character
I also think that things are not going
to get better if you turn this thing
over at this point to a Democrat who not
only has similar character flaws but
also is dedicated to rooting out
fundamental notions of the Constitution
but put the Trump stuff aside George
Will has a new book out it's called the
conservative Sensibility and it
basically is a comparison between
Madisonian democracy the ideas that are
imbed
in the Declaration of Independence in
the Constitution versus Woodrow Wilson's
progressive Revolution looks about 500
pages it is a a real tour de force by
George well it is sort of a life's work
you can see it it's it's embedded in
every page I have some substance have
disagreements with will on the nature of
that Madisonian democracy on the nature
of what stands behind our rules of
natural rights but his contrast between
the founding and the Progressive Era is
exactly correct and his explication of
the stuff is quite beautiful his writing
is quite beautiful the book is called
the conservative Sensibility I would
suggest that our disagreements lie more
in sort of the the understanding of the
roots of the American Revolution and
founding era philosophy as wills is a
very secular take on this mine is a
little bit more I think a historically
based religious take on it but with that
said the book itself is really good and
all the criticism he's receiving right
now because he's anti Trump people say
he's not conservative guys George Will
has spent his entire career
being conservative you know if the
conservative movement can't handle
people who don't like a particular
president I would suggest the
conservative movement is doomed to
failure so I would recommend the book
it's called the conservative Sensibility
it's really good I'm enjoying it right
now I'm in the middle of it so go check
that out okay other things that I like
today so there's this ironic this is
sort of ironic so there's an article by
Catelyn Beattie called how should
Christians have sex it says purity
culture was harmful and dangerous but
its collapse has left a void for those
of us looking for guidance in our
intimate lives the entire article is
basically about how you if you suggest
that sex should be reserved for marriage
you're bad but also getting rid of that
standard has basically destroyed sex in
our culture so the entire article is I
don't like this original standard but I
also realize all of the standards that
supplanted it are basically garbage at
least for human beings who want to be
happy and so now I'm stuck well maybe it
should rethink like a first statement
maybe that's what you should do this
author writes when I was 14 a circuit
speaker came to my church's youth group
to talk about sexual purity
I don't remember many details from the
talk but vividly recall signing a True
Love Waits pledge a small note card
promising out remain a virgin until
marriage 20 years later that ritual
strikes me as almost innocuous how much
power do we give to a scribbled
signature of a teenager who had only the
faintest idea what sex was
and it also carried a psychological
burden that many of my peers and I are
still unloading this is where we get the
whole it was such a burden to be half to
expecting us to have a moral standard to
wait until me oh my god I'm still living
that down get over it
like seriously get over you're an adult
now get over it a majority of adults who
came of age in evangelical churches in
the 90s and 2000's we're exposed to
purity culture a term for teachings that
stressed sexual abstinence before
marriage I urged this by the way we had
our own rituals such as purity balls in
our own merchandise such as purity
ring's I had to wait from eternal that I
kept as a college freshman created by a
prominent Christian pop singer the
journal was designed to hold letters to
my future husband it held out the
promise that if I remain pure and God
would reward good behavior with a
husband
surely before I turned 30 so that we
could have lots of children well no
actually nothing in purity culture
suggests that God is a gumball machine
I'm so sick of people who think that God
is a gumball machine okay it's not
that's not the way God works it's not
like you do what God wants and then God
gives you everything that you could
possibly want that make a bad person by
the way if the only reason to do things
is because you think God is then going
to give you what you want because you
bribe God you have a mistaken idea of
God and also a mistaken idea of morality
the idea instead is that if you wait
until marriage to have sex you are
saving yourself for your spouse and if
your spouse saves themselves for you
then you get to enjoy one of the most
wonderful things God ever created with
the person that you trust and love the
most without having to think about all
of the prior experiences with people or
without a meaning or debasing yourself
now again this is not to suggest that if
people have premarital sex they've done
something irredeemable or terrible or
anything like that but from a religious
perspective and from I think a basic
natural law perspective the idea of sex
within marriage makes a lot of sense it
makes a lot of sense and it is
spiritually fulfilling and I speak as
someone who is a virgin until marriage
as was my wife and I'm proud of that I
think that's a good thing I don't think
it's a bad thing to teach our children
in fact I am going to teach it to our
children I think it's a very very good
thing to teach to children that sex is
important enough that you ought to wait
for somebody that you love enough to
actually spend a lifelong commitment
with and if you can't reach that if you
if you decide differently or you make a
mistake or whatever that is you're an
adult those are decisions that you can
make but to have a standard and not to
live up to a standard is one thing to
say the standard itself is wrong or bad
or damaging I think that's very silly
so this lady writes somehow God and I
got our wires crossed because the
husband hasn't arrived again it ain't
got it in and God for you to find a
husband it really is not when people
blame all everything bad that happens to
them on God or the society around them I
start to think that you have a mistaken
impression of how cause and effect work
twenty years later I no longer subscribe
to purity culture largely because it
never had anything to say to Christians
past the age of 23 oh really I was 24
and I got married weird yeah lately I
also find myself mourning the loss of
the coherent sexual ethic the purity
culture tried to offer is the consent
culture the best that we have in its
place this is the best part right so now
she realizes okay so I didn't like that
now I'm in my 30s and I've had sex and
all that but I'm really not liking the
new secular standard yeah that's right
you're not cuz the new secular standard
sucks the standard that basically says
that consent alone makes for good sex or
makes for good relationships or
spiritually fulfilling consent is a
great standard for law it is not
necessarily a great standard for
morality there are lots of things to
which people consent that are demeaning
and bad for them that doesn't mean they
should be illegal I'm a libertarian but
it does mean that maybe those things are
damaging to you which is why you don't
teach them to your children prostitution
is a consensual act as a general rule it
is it is a consensual act putting aside
you know pressures or how people got
into prostitution the act of
prostitution itself is an act of consent
which is why I'm very torn on its
legalization does that mean that it is
good for either the prostitute or the
John I don't think so so this person
says the effects of purity culture are
well documented in books like Linda rake
lines Linda K Klein's pure and in ex of
Angelica online communities rather than
emphasize the gift of sex within
marriage purity culture typically led
with the shame of having sex outside of
it I don't think that's true at all you
literally just said one second ago that
you kept a journal of letters to your
prospective husband about the gift of
sex within marriage like what what it is
hilarious to me that there are so many
people on the second door left who have
decided and this woman is still crystal
considered self Christian by the way so
I'm not labeling her secular left but
her perspective on sex is much more
secular than Christian they got rid of
the traditional standard and then their
solution to the differential standard
was a completely unworkable standard and
now they're sad that the standard is
gone here's how this lady
the author of a woman's place completes
her article occasionally I think about
my purity pledge and letters to mystic
my mystical future husband and find
those practices naive and manipulative
but part of me wishes that the fairy
tale of purity culture had come true
well I hate the effects the purity
culture had on young women like me again
no you made choices you're an adult I
still find the traditional Christian
vision for married sex radical daunting
and extremely compelling and what I
still want to uphold even if I fumble
along the way so in the end you end up
coming back around to the standard well
maybe the problem was with you not
upholding the standard if you're so
upset about not upholding the standard
if you don't want to pull the standard
don't it's free country but to pretend
that the standard is bad simply because
you had a bad emotional response to the
standard is to is to get rid of rules in
favor of subjective feeling which is not
something I like okay time for some
things that I hate we have now reached
the point of utter absurdity
there is a transgender track star which
is to say a genetic male named CC Telfer
CC Topher was apparently a middling
sprinter as a male now see see Topher
considers himself a transgender woman
and he competes on the Franklin Pierce
University track team not surprisingly
he is now world-class because he is
running against women so here's what
Cece tell but Cece Telford says no no no
you understand I'm disadvantaged running
against women which comes as a shock to
all of the women who are getting beat by
a guy who has six inches and a
significant amount of musculature to his
advantage anything mean competing
against this genders females is a
disadvantage because my body is going on
going through so many medical
implications like it's going through
biochemistry changes arm so being on you
know hormone replacement therapy it it
gives you it so it's you you're your
muscle depletion your muscle is
deteriorating you lose a lot of strength
because you know testosterone is where
you get your strength agility all of
that um athletic stuff so I have to work
twice as hard to keep that strength um
okay can we go back to some of the
pictures here okay this is a picture of
Cece Topher next to people who are
competing with CeCe Topher Cece Topher
is a very large human being
Cece Telfer how tall do you think this
person is closing in on six
probably this person is a very large
human standing next to a bunch of very
small women and then now competing those
very small women CC Telfer won the
women's 400 meter hurdles at the NCAA
Division 2 championship
I wonder why how could this have
happened maybe it's because CC Telfer is
a genetic male and there are differences
between male and female and this is all
idiotic idiotic
I understand hormone treatments not
great for your body also when you start
off as a man who is six inches taller
than every woman on the field with the
musculature of a man the depletion still
not gonna compare to having grown up as
a woman with estrogen but I guess we
just have to be as stupid as humanly
possible
put all objective fact out of your mind
instead favor the the feelings of people
who are engaged in the delusion that
they are physically the same as women I
mean this is just because that's what
this person is saying basic they're at a
disadvantage as compared to women mmm
that's why you're defeating them handily
when you couldn't compete with the males
perfect yes I'm sure
Hey other things that I hate so people
who judge needs a course in stats
apparently the the mayor of South Bend
Indiana did an interview on Axios on HBO
in which he explained that he was not
the first gay president here he is
making this bizarre convention if you
were to win the nomination they'll say
you're too young too liberal too gay to
be commander-in-chief you are young you
are liberal you are gay how are you
responding I'll respond by explaining
where I want to lead this country people
will elect the person who will make the
best president and we have had excellent
presidents who have been young we have
that excellent presidents who have been
liberal I would imagine we've probably
had excellent presidents who were gay we
just didn't know which ones you believe
that we've had a gay commander-in-chief
I mean statistically it's almost certain
and like in your reading of history like
do you believe you know who they were my
gaydar doesn't even work that well in
the present let alone retro actively but
one can only assume that's the case I'm
Wyatt come on only assume that's the
case like there have been 44 presidents
about 2% of the population is gay so
statistically speaking we pretty I mean
first of all presidents are not elected
on the basis of statistics
Stickley speaking 10% of our presidents
should have been black nope
statistically speaking half of our
presidents should have been women if we
are just doing representation of the
population so nope on that one as well
so just two typically speaking no also
when he says some of our great
presidents would have been gays
statistically speaking we've had like
three good presidents so probably not
the only one who probably was gay
according to at least or at least
possibly was gay according to most
historians was James Buchanan who you
know I don't know that gay folks
actually want to claim James Buchanan
pretty widely considered the worst
president in American history not
because he was gay but because he was a
crap president so this is all very weird
and I'm just weirded out by the idea
that people judge has to make the claim
that other presidents were gay in order
for him to be legitimate as a gay
president that's that's silly to me
again I don't think most Americans
really care or whether people who to
judge is gay Mike Pence who he has been
to riding doesn't care the people who to
judge his gay I don't really think a lot
of Americans give a crap about this but
I guess making up history and stats is
one strategy I suppose
already well we'll be back here later
today with two additional hours of
content otherwise we'll see you here
tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Savitz audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
hey everyone its Andrew clave and host
of the Andrew Clavin show the poet
William Wordsworth wrote that his heart
leaped up when he beheld a rainbow in
the sky well unfortunately the rainbow
has come down to earth and here it's a
sign of woke oppression a weapon bent on
the abolition of man I'll explain on the
Andrew Klavan show on Andrew Klavan